all right we're on problem number five
let me make sure my microphone
okay problem number five
if m to the x
m to the x
times m to the seventh
is equal to 28
and they also tell us that m to the
fifth
and then that whole thing to the y power
is equal to
m to the 15th
what is the value of x plus
y x plus y equals 1.
so this is really just a test of whether
you know your exponent rules
so what is m to the x times m to the
seventh
so your temptation might have been to
say 7x but no remember when you multiply
two numbers of the same base and the
base is m you add the exponents so it's
m to the x plus seven and they actually
wanted to tempt you to do seven x
because you actually use the number 28
here which is a multiple of seven so
they were tempting you to do 7x but we
know that you add the exponents when you
multiply
m to the x times m to the seventh and so
we have
m to the
x times m to the seventh oh sorry
i wrote it down wrong
it equals m to the 28th sorry well you
knew that anyway m to the x times m to
the seventh is equal to m to the x plus
seven and that equals m to the 28.
so the exponents have to equal each
other so x plus seven
is equal to 28
x is equal to
21.
now let's go here
here we have m to the fifth and then
we're raising that to the y power so
here we actually would multiply the
exponents if you remember your exponent
rule so you have m
to the 5y
is equal to m to the 15th
so 5y must equal 15.
5y is equal to
15 y is equal to 3.
so what's x plus y it's 21
plus 3 which equals 24
and that is choice d
next problem
looks like there's going to be some
drawing for sal in this problem
try my best oh i thought i was using
little uh undo un edit undo
but i was using the line tool okay
it's my y axis draw a straight line i
drew a straight line
that's my
x-axis
and then what do they have here they
have 19 let's see 1985
so 1985
and then 90.
let's see 1985
is
maybe looks about 148 000
so if this is
1985 is here
let me just
let me just draw it all out 1985 then
1986 is up here at 160 000.
this is 140.
so 1986 is up here at 160 000
1987 is a little bit
is a little bit less 1987 looks like
about 150 i don't know eyeballing 156.
1987 is here
1987 is there
let's see 1988 looks like a little bit
above
140 000.
1988 is a little bit above 140 000.
1989 is between 130 120.
all the work here is drawing
you hopefully already have in your book
so where was i
oh sorry this is 1988.
1988 was a little bit better than 140
000 sorry ignore that one 1989
looks like about a hundred and i don't
know 26
1989 is 126.
the 1990s
i don't know 112 or something 1990
is out here
110 that's 110 and then if i were to
connect them connect the dots
look something like that
looks something like that
and then let's read the question
according to the graph above which of
the following is closest to the decrease
per year in the number of homes sold
between 1987 and 1990.
so we're talking about from 1987 so it's
from this year to 1990.
so how much did we decrease in the first
year right the first year we decreased
by this much and i'm going to look in
the book because i don't know how good i
how well i drew this graph but in 1987
it looks like we're about
it looks like about 156 000
56 and then as we go to 1988
if we go to 1988 it looks like about 142
000 just eyeballing it
right so
142 000.
right so this distance right here is
what it would be 156 minus 142. it's
about minus 14 000.
right that's how much we changed over
this one year
and if i look at the choices there
already is choice c which is 14 000 but
let me just do one more just to make
sure
so if we wanted to figure out from 1988
to 1989 so we said 1988 is it 142 000.
where is 1989
looks like
looks like 128 or
120 i would say 128 000.
i would say this is about 128 thousand
and so that would also 142 minus 128
that's also
14k
and then if we do the last one that's
128 and then this looks like about 114
right here
114.
so this is also 14 000. so the answer is
c 14 000
next problem
problem seven
here we have this diagram
that shows up actually a lot when you're
taking the sat i'll show you why
this is a very common thing you'll see
this
let me see and then there's a line like
that
it's a line like that
and then they connect it here
now let's read the problem
let's read this problem
i already have suspicion what they're
going to ask
so let's see this is a
b
c
d
and e
they tell us this is perpendicular
this is perpendicular this is x this is
y
in the figure above a e
and c d a e and c d are each
perpendicular to c e fair enough
if x is equal to y
the length of a b is four so a b is four
and x is equal to y
and the length of b d is eight like the
bd is eight what is the length of ce so
we're trying to figure out let me draw
ce
let's have our goal in a different color
we're trying to figure out this line
right there
and one thing i didn't write they told
us x is equal to y so immediately that
should hit a trigger x is equal to y
and this is a 90 degree angle so we know
that
you know x plus y plus 90 is equal to
or that x plus y is equal to 90 and if
they're equal to each other
x must equal y which equals 45 degrees
right
so this is 45
this is 45 and if y is 45 what is this
angle going to be well it's opposite to
y
so this will also be
45 degrees
and this is a right angle too
so 45 plus 90 plus this angle has to
equal 180 so what's this angle going to
be
well that's also going to be 45 degrees
this also has to be a 45 45 90 triangle
if you ever see a triangle where one of
the angles is 90 the other is 45 the
other one has to be 45 because they add
up to 180.
and what we want to figure out is this
length here
so i'm going to show you a little trick
and this trick well it doesn't always
work it's not really a trick it's just a
visualization
exercise really and say we want to
figure out this length
well that length i'm going to say i'm
going to make the claim and i think
you'll believe this claim is the same as
this length i'm just essentially
creating a rectangle
it's the same as that length
right so if we figure out this length we
solve the problem this this light brown
length
and we also know
let me draw the bottom
do we know the the length actually
actually we don't even have to
this bottom line we don't know the
length of that bottom line we need to
figure out this length
we know
since this line is parallel to this line
we know this is a 90 degree angle
well do we know the hypotenuse of this
sure the hypotenuse is 4 plus 8 it's
this big red line and let me draw the
hypotenuse in a different color
the hypotenuse
right here that's the hypotenuse
actually i'm running out of time so i'm
going to continue this
in the next video see you soon